pas en vient maintenant la principale
information de ce week-end c'est bien
sûr la situation au japon après le
tremblement de terre le tsunami qui s'en
est suivi la menace nucléaire qui pèse
sur plusieurs sites du pays le dernier
bilan fait état de près de dix mille
disparus alors comment est né ce chaos
tout avait commencé et bien vendredi ils
étaient 14h46 au japon au tour en images
avec olivier caroff le monde entier a
découvert ces images en direct juste
sous l'hélicoptère de la télévision
japonaise
une muraille des cubes dit n'être d'où
elle avance à 600 kilomètres heure prête
à dévorer la côte nord-est du japon
sa force destructrice elle l'a trouvé
dans un séisme de magnitude 9
deux minutes de terreur sans
interruption a tokyo les gratte-ciel
tang
c'est visible à l'oeil nu et à
l'intérieur ce bruit et la structure qui
risque
la secousse ébranle tout l'archipel
de nombreux japonais font les gestes
qu'ils ont appris et répété tant de fois
d'autres semblent pétrifiée ce
tremblement de terre n'est pas comme les
précédents voici un stade à 300 km de
l'épicentre
la tribune a tenu les pylônes aussi une
chance d autres images prises sur le vif
le premier ministre au parlement
personne ne le réalisent alors mais le
désastre commence lorsque kamaishi à
plus de 100 km de l'épicentre
la mer est entré dans la terre elle
s'engouffre dans les rues il alerte au
tsunami avait été annoncé par haut
parleurs une partie de la population a
eu le temps de se précipiter sur les
hauteurs elle assiste impuissante à la
destruction de plus au nord rien ne
résiste à la vague géante zone agricole
route
tout est recouvert en quelques instants
la moindre dénivellation devient un
piège mortel
la marée boueuse prend tout le monde de
vitesse
l'outil les voitures les camions les
trains
capable de précipiter les bateaux
n'importe où
de soulever des maisons entières pour
les emporter et les broyer beaucoup plus
loin
des kilomètres de côtes vont subir le
même sort parmi les lieux les plus
touchés minami sanriku c'était une ville
portuaire voici tout ce qui en émerge
désormais dans cette seule région
le bilan dépasserait selon les autorités
les dix mille morts rares sont les
miracles une femme retrouvée vivante
dans sa voiture où ce bus laissé de côté
par la furie des eaux
séisme tsunami et hier une dernière
image glaçante
cette explosion au loin une centrale
nucléaire
sous le toit éventré un réacteur en
surchauffe au japon l'homme n'est plus
seulement confronté à la nature mais à
sa propre création
et on va prendre
[Musique]